this identity now this identity is not
very nice it doesn't look very nice to
start with is like oh no it's cubed and
if you were if you didn't know what else
to do you may well have expanded that
cube okay which as you can see is a bad
idea I keeping anything is a bad idea
okay even though you can't do it seeing
that there's a cos x minus sine x over
there that's my target since i started
the left hand side right i see that i
can get a kha'zix minus sign except this
by factorizing right so remember even
though like simplify things as far as
you can is a good idea usually always
try and think about where you're going
where's your destination because that's
my destination when I look at this
numerator I think about the fastest path
to get there and the fastest part is
factorization it's the difference of
squares okay once I've got that like and
this is the way the trig identity was
constructed you've got this guy common
with that thing being raised to the
third power on the denominator so it
simply get scattered like so okay which
of course is obvious what you see it but
if you don't see it it's very hard to
see I guess my clue would be see how its
cubed right like boy that's going to
look like a pain and I'm trying to give
you a clue over here on the right hand
side so as much as possible and
experience obviously helps with this
don't just simplify by Lee or don't
explain expand blindly go into direction
all right so I canceled at this point I
know I must expand and that's because
I'm like look I want a one on the bottom
where's that one going to come from the
best candidate is the Pythagorean
identity cos squared plus sine squared
okay so once that turns into one you've
already got two sine x cos x there which
is already signed two eggs and lo and
behold it just falls out which is nice
once you see it ok do be aware though
under pressure under time pressure I
would honestly look at this question and
if it doesn't snap into focus in ten
seconds I'm moving on that's exam
technique right you like I could waste I
could waste eight minutes on this or I
could just move on get some marks come
back to it maybe
get it maybe I do okay but at least you
would have wasted time oh ok so think
about that don't get bogged down last 14
ko's a plus 3 equals 0 and 10 a is
positive find the exact value so there
are lots of ways to do this I felt like
the most efficient way was to make kaze
the subject so you get a value right
there therefore kaze is negative so I'm
in the third or fourth quadrants 10 a is
positive so I must be in the third
quadrant let's are there I am and then
what a cool that means I've gotta fix
something yeah once I've got that I draw
a triangle if it's 3 over 4 i've got
adjacent over hypotenuse which gives me
the other side by Pythagoras right
because this guy over here is 16 the
square root of sixteen minus 9 done
alright so that's where my screen of
seven comes from now I go through these
pieces here 10 a minus 180 ok now the
easiest way to say that see it is to say
well 10 is periodic every 180 degrees so
tener minus 180 you can just read off
that's 10 a ok alternatively if you
didn't see that right away you could say
well I know how to expand 10 a minus B
10 of a minus B where in this case B is
180 is 10 a minus 10 b / help me out one
plus ten a ten be very good and 10b is
180 even if you don't remember your
calculator can verify you for you the 10
a 10 at 180 is 0 right so you're getting
10 a minus 0 1 plus 10 8 times 0 which
gives you back 10 8 just like we said
before so once you realize that it's
today you just read it off the triangle
its opposite on adjacent route 73